NATO, the North Atlantic Treaty Organization,
the most important military alliance in the
world, has just turned 70.
This anniversary comes in the midst of one
of the most significant political and diplomatic
crises it has suffered in its entire history.
Today on VISUALPOLITIK, you and I will get
to know NATO a little better.
Because... as 2019 marks the anniversary of
NATO, some of the VISUALPOLITIK team traveled
to Romania to learn more about how this organization
works, to talk to some of the people in charge
and to witness NATO maneuvers live.
Don’t tell me that isn’t a fitting way
to celebrate its 70th birthday.
(We visited the exercise “Vigorous Warrior
2019”.
It was held in Sibiu, Romania.)
This video is one of three videos in which
we’ll try to get to know this institution
a little bit better, we’ll see how it works
today, how it has changed over the years and
the challenges it faces for the years ahead.
So... without further ado, let's go.
On April 4th, 1949, the treaty of the North
Atlantic was signed, which led to NATO, the
most important military alliance of all time.
Throughout these 70 years, the organization
has changed a lot, but most significantly,
it has grown.
You see, it was originally it was an agreement
between 12 countries.
Today, it has no less than 29 members.
The United States, Canada, Turkey and 26 other
European states, including several former
members of the Warsaw Pact which was the former
military alliance formed between the Soviet
Union and the Eastern Bloc countries.
Very soon, The Republic of North Macedonia
will become the 30th member of the organization.
Folks, we’re talking about an alliance that
represents almost one billion people, half
of the world's economic power and most of
the world’s military spending.
An organization with joint command structures
and troops that train together to be able
to respond to a crisis in a coordinated manner.
This global defence alliance wields an unprecedented
power.
Because, folks, the 29 countries that currently
constitute NATO, have an accumulated annual
military spending of more than one trillion
US dollars.
That is, almost 60% of all the military spending
of all the countries in the world.
But hold on just a moment.
Despite having most of the world’s military
spending power, and being bigger and more
powerful than ever before, NATO isn’t exactly
enjoying its golden era..
This is something we have already talked about
in several videos on VISUALPOLITIK.
Well, in this and two upcoming videos, we’ll
explain what’s happening and how NATO has
evolved over the years, the threats it faces
and its possible future.
But let’s start with a bit of history.
(THE THREAT OF THE RED ARMY)
The 1940s are about to end.
The Second World War ended just four years
prior.
The greatest conflict of all time has left
tens of millions of war victims, not only
direct war deaths but countless additional
lives cut short due to disease and the political
brutality of totalitarian ideologies.
The end of the Second World War meant the
end of Nazism, but at the same time, it also
led to the emergence of a new split that would
divide not only Europe, but also the world,
for decades.
Folks, the Cold War had started.
At that time, The European continent was devastated,
it was economically shattered and its armies
were tattered and demobilized
However, there was an important difference
between Eastern and Western Europe.
On the one hand, Eastern Europe was under
the Soviet Union’s control, which maintained
more than five million soldiers in the region
for many years.
On the other hand, the presence of US and
UK troops on the continent shrunk very quickly.
Between 1945 and 1946 the contingents from
these two countries deployed in continental
Europe dropped from 4.5 million soldiers to
less than 900,000.
That is to say, by the end of the 40s, the
difference in favor of the Soviet troops was
of 5 to 1.
That’s a huge difference.
And not only that, at that time communism
was an expanding political force... spreading
to countries all around the globe.
And of course Moscow was very, very certain
that it wasn’t going to loosen its grip
on Europe.
Want an example?
Well… check this out.
In 1947, the Czech Republic accepted the Marshall
Plan... but was soon after forced to renounce
due to pressure from Moscow.
Only a year later, in 1948, there was a coup
that placed the country firmly under communist
control.
In that same year, the Soviet Union carried
out the Berlin Blockade, meaning West Berlin
had to be supplied by a staggering airlift
of 900 daily flights for months on end.
Anyway, folks, these were the circumstances
that created real fear in Western Europe that
the Soviet troops would advance to occupy
new countries, such as the Federal Republic
of Germany, or even the entire continent.
It was for precisely this reason that France,
the United Kingdom, Belgium, the Netherlands
and Luxembourg swiftly agreed on a mutual
defense clause in the Brussels Treaty.
This was also done in 1948.
But fearing that this wasn’t enough; these
countries quickly turned to the United States:
the defense of Europe’s free countries had
to be ensured.
And that’s how, finally, on April 4th, 1949,
12 countries – France, the Netherlands,
Belgium, Luxembourg, Denmark, the United Kingdom,
Norway, Italy, Iceland, Portugal, Canada and
the United States – signed the Treaty of
Washington or the North Atlantic Treaty that
gave birth to NATO.
NATO’s first Secretary General, Lord Ismay,
summed up the goal of the alliance as “keeping
the Soviet Union out, the Americans in, and
the Germans down”.
Kai Weiss, Research and Outreach Officer at
the Austrian Economics Center.)
It was precisely in this founding treaty that
famous Article 5 was established:
The parties agree that an armed attack against
one or more of them in Europe or North America
shall be considered an attack against them
all.)
In other words, a very clear agreement: all
for one and one for all.
"We hope to create a shield against aggression
and the fear of aggression; a bulwark which
will permit us to get on with the real business
of government and society; the business of
achieving a fuller and happier life for all
our citizens.”
Harry S. Truman, President of the United States
of America)
But... it didn’t stop there.
In 1952, Turkey and Greece joined the alliance
and three years later, in 1955, the German
Federal Republic joined.
And it was soon after that the Soviet Union
and the Eastern Bloc countries, except for
Yugoslavia, created their own alliance, the
Warsaw Pact;
An alliance that unified the power of all
of Europe’s socialist countries:
We’re talking about more than six million
soldiers, 65,000 tanks, 15,000 combat aircraft,
2,000 warships and nuclear missiles distributed
among the member states.
Europe was truly divided, two great military
alliances confronted each other across a line
sketched on a map.
So, at this point, you may be wondering.
What has NATO really done?
How many missions, how many interventions
have they led?
How has the alliance changed?
Listen up.
(A DECISIVE YEAR)
After the fall of the Berlin Wall and the
collapse of the Soviet Union, NATO, an organization
created to face the Soviet threat, didn’t
decrease its activity.
On the contrary: it slowly began to have a
much more active role, both inside and outside
Europe.
Throughout this process, 1999 was a key year.
In that year, three new countries joined the
alliance: Poland, Hungary and the Czech Republic.
Remember that these three countries had once
belonged to the Warsaw Pact and had therefore
been seen by NATO for decades as enemy countries.
It was, folks, the beginning of a process
that over the years led NATO to include a
large number of former Eastern Bloc countries
that had been under Soviet control:
Latvia, Lithuania, Estonia, Bulgaria, Romania...
even Albania.
This huge expansion of NATO infuriated the
Russian political elite, but gave the organization
much more strength while also aiding these
newly independent countries to accelerate
and consolidate their reforms without fear
of reprisals from Russia.
But that, folks, isn’t all.
1999 was also the year where NATO carried
out its first major offensive:
It intervened in the former Yugoslavia to
stop the ethnic cleansing that the Serbian
leader, Slobodan Milosevic, was carrying out
against the Kosovo Albanian population.
To stop the Serbian government, NATO carried
out heavy attacks against political and military
targets.
Folks, NATO’s spirit had changed, it was
no longer just a defensive organization.
At any given moment, there was even speculation
of a possible terrestrial invasion of Serbia
with NATO troops.
And, you know what?
It is rumored that the then Russian leader,
Boris Yeltsin was so humiliated and enraged
because NATO had dared to include Eastern
European countries in its alliance, that he
threatened a Third World War.
If NATO’s troops tried to occupy Serbia,
Russia would respond.
“I have warned NATO, the Americans and the
Germans not to push us into military action,
otherwise there will certainly be a European
war and maybe a world war.”
Boris Yeltsin, President of Russia)
In a way, years later in 2008, Moscow's threats
became a reality.
Georgia’s approach, by Mikhail Sahasvilli,
to the European Union and above all to NATO,
led the Russian government to unleash a war
against this country.
The point, folks, is that in the last few
years we’ve seen NATO take a much more active
role.
In addition to their continued expansion and
the intervention in Serbia, NATO has also
intervened in Afghanistan, Iraq and Libya.
And this has led to huge controversy:
The current debate goes something like this.
Should NATO become an institution that acts
where needed to protect its member states,
even if they aren’t under direct attack?
Should it step in if human rights are being
seriously violated anywhere in the world?
Or should it be limited to being exclusively
a defense alliance, that is, limit itself
to act only if a member country is militarily
attacked?
In short, does NATO make sense today as it
was originally intended?
And, be careful, because the implications
of this debate are huge.
After all, we’re talking about the future
of the world and the role of the most important
military alliance of all time.
We’re talking about a debate that is at
the forefront and that in recent times has
had the President of the United States, Donald
Trump, as an undisputed protagonist.
He claims that NATO no longer works, that
it doesn’t make sense, that it should become
obsolete.
And this gives rise to another question.
So far NATO has always worked under the leadership
of the United States, but...
Could it still work and have a future if the
United States stepped down from its leadership
position?
Even if the US remained a member, could NATO
be compatible with a new European military
leadership structure?
This is a topic that we’ve already talked
about here on VISUALPOLITIK on several occasions,
but folks, we’ll take a more detailed look
in a future video.
For now, we can say that despite their problems
and mistakes, NATO has been a huge success.
I mean, Europe today enjoys an environment
of peace, safety and cooperation between countries.
Come on, it’s like a gang of good friends.
And don’t think that this was always the
case.
Nothing could be further from the truth.
For centuries, conflicts and wars between
European nations were routine events, and
even after the Second World War, the tension
between the West and the East only flourished.
In many respects NATO fulfilled its purpose
perfectly, even though its member countries
haven’t always gotten along and have had
their good and bad times, like when France
withdrew from the joint military structure
– not the alliance – in 1966.
Anyway folks, that’s the story of how NATO
was born, grew and changed.
In a future video we’ll examine what the
alliance means today and what threats it faces.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did, and don’t forget to
subscribe for brand new videos.
Don’t forget to check out our friends at
the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the voiceover in this episode.
Also, this channel is possible because of
Patreon, and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent political
coverage.
And as always, I’ll see you in the next
video.